what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch today
zack snyder's justice league the mother
box origins
official exclusive clip from ign fan
fest who has a long time you guys know
i'm going out we're going to watch this
all right let's get into it
hey guys sorry to interrupt but uh this
video supposed to get up yesterday the
video
got blocked in some countries because of
the song and i expected it to be
demonetized because of the song
so what i did was i disputed it in hopes
that
like hey it's fine if this video is
demonetized because i just feel like it
feels weird without the music being here
but i just want it to be available in
all countries unfortunately
dispute still stands so i just had no
choice but to
completely mute the music entirely for
this edit but you know there's still the
reaction and there's still plenty of
commentary afterwards so
hope you can still enjoy
football helmet cyborg
it's cool they lead with him yeah
especially uh with the connection with
their mother boxes
wayne manor wow
whoa
huh flashlight
at a time vault damn
this is beautiful this is the opening or
something all right
maybe
trident i love you chose a different
leonard cohen so
is senator cohen i thought this was tom
waits you know they
they occupy a similar space
sounds like tom i'm not sure either now
god he's beautiful
wow
it's christ-like figure
you know they're rebooting him what
they've confirmed caval though right
oh dude this is gorgeous
yeah camera and artifact is that the
original
aries helmet in the back there now you
guys see a little codex there a little
little superman codex there krypton
codex
cool what a neat tease yeah what a neat
gorgeous tease
yeah i can see that being the opening to
the movie
yeah i mean i could see that being maybe
a credit sequence or something you know
if they
you get those credits out for this zack
snyder watchman vibes especially from
that too
it's so like beautiful in a way as a way
of immortalizing the characters and sort
of paying homage to the fact that they
are
these almost larger-than-life
deity-esque beings even though they are
just from our fictions
it's interesting looking at this wonder
woman image because i mean you got the
dr
poison mask over here and i can't tell
if that's steppenwolf's helmet but i
remember there was a different design
they had for ares originally
i think that was supposed to show up in
this i think that might be
that version i wouldn't put it past it
if i'm not mistaken and i love
like the arrangement of how the mother
boxes do form
and like box-like shapes like little
boxes making the mother boxes
geometric patterns but it also reminds
me kind of of the pattern
that was like that in a man of steel
when it came to the codex
and uh or how a lot of the kryptonian
ships worked
yeah they have this sort of like pagan
slide
yeah thing yeah and there's again that
is those like geometric it's almost like
one of those like
nail reverse image things but you know
more high tech
oh man i i feel like you can totally
make some great merch out of this [ __ ]
like a placard like a metal placard that
you could put for the
like the batman one slightly looks like
it forms a little bit of a color when
the lightning flashes on it mm-hmm
oh someone's gonna make a replica of
this that's like all
all sided and it's gonna have every
character and it's gonna be like full
detail and it's gonna cost
forty thousand dollars in the fall and
darkness of the justice league right
here yeah one i love to use two of just
the flames you know like breaking
through from the other side
it's interesting with a couple of things
i've been going on lately the superman
reboots happening the main thing that's
being discussed is that they're looking
to reboot superman
with uh making black person of color i
mean if you guys know us
you know that for the first people to
champion a decision like that
the last person to criticize a decision
like that that's not a problem
i would love to see a black superman the
thing that i'm not in favor of
is not continuing henry cavill or at
least letting him give a proper
conclusion to it
especially because of the fact that
we've wanted a man of steel two
done properly henry cavill's been
wanting to continue being superman and i
recently
watched man of steel like a few days ago
i've never had such a
higher appreciation for that movie than
i do now and his performance as well
and you can see the trajectory where his
arc was going and maybe
it'll feel like a proper conclusion with
zack snyder's justice league the fact
that making all these different
universes
and dimensional stuff i think it's maybe
the way it's being pitched a superman
reboot you know so if it's a new
superman
and you have like one that is
paralleling in a different world where
you got this other superman this black
superman whatever
doesn't matter what race he is to me
honestly he's an alien doesn't freaking
matter to me if he's white or
black or mexican it doesn't matter the
thing that i get
concerned about is you're not going to
continue henry cavill superman
and i just find it interesting in the
midst of promoting
zack snyder's justice league why i'm
taking the time to talk about this now
is because
we're in the middle of promoting zack
snyder's justice league you know you got
the superman imagery here people are
excited for black suit superman mary
cavill
to have more on-screen time in this
version as well the only thing that bums
me out
is the thought of henry cavill will not
get to
finish yeah continue i mean hell they
even having like ben affleck and now
they're bringing him back for flashpoint
and hopefully putting a stamp on that
you know
yeah and i'm like we hear nothing about
any of that other than just
rumors with henry cavill so that's kind
of just the
the jarring thing that popped up to my
head right here i even pointed it out
it's like yeah they're rebooting him and
have it just run in some different
universe henry cavill just have one more
one more put a final stamp on this
please it does seem like the dangling
thread of the dceu because to an extent
everybody you can see has either gotten
a sense of due or is about to be given
it
through justice league and yeah the one
person who i can imagine justice league
maybe not doing that for completely
given the redemption and return arc he
needs to be on his superman yeah
i'm quite curious and the only thing i'm
trying to take comfort in is
maybe because of all the
multi-dimensional stuff
everyone's doing right now maybe this
won't be the last we see of henry cavill
and zack sander did say that
he kept his cliffhanger ending in this
one uh-huh
and now there's no plans for a sequel
but i'm doing my cliffhanger ending in
here
yeah it makes me wonder because i at the
end of the day i'm like well wb
probably has the final say in all of
this but at the same time i'm like i
don't know maybe if somebody was like
hey
we liked where you were going and uh
we'd like to help you continue that who
knows maybe they could work some joint
venture out elsewhere it seems like a t
backs
the hell out of zack snyder but warner
brothers does not bag zack snyder that's
just the way it seems
right even zack snyder's interview that
we were that we broke down it's like
this guy is not shy about talking about
warner brothers
right now and i can't blame him now
after all he's been through with this
and especially the fact that they're
keeping
the cliffhanger ending in here and if
this movie proves to be a success for at
t they're going to want to do another
one public negotiation and then
maybe we'll be able to get han the
superman reboot of whatever the hell
they want to do i support a person of
color playing superman what i don't like
is the idea of
completely canning henry cavill in order
to do another
reboot of superman that that's it that's
all i'm trying to say
especially when they have more people
from henry cavill's side of the dc
universe with upcoming features you know
on the slate
and then seeing especially like from
watching matt steele seeing the imager
here i'm like
no man we had to happen to ben affleck
let's get it let's keep henry cavill
going damn it
all right guys well what'd you think of
this imagery i thought it was absolutely
gorgeous i imagine this would be like a
um i imagine there's a lot of easter
eggs that just totally flew over my head
in here
obviously because i noticed a couple of
little things but i'm sure there's
plenty of other things i did not notice
in the middle of it all right
well leave your thoughts down below talk
with you guys soon